supongamos que aquí dibujo un cuadrado
es decir un cuadrilátero en el cual los
cuatro lados miden lo mismo y los lados
adyacentes son perpendiculares
cada uno de estos ángulos es de 90
grados vale e imagínate que te digo que
la medida del lado del cuadrado es de 8
metros es decir cada uno de sus cuatro
lados miden 8 metros y que a partir de
eso te pido determinar su área área
como le haríamos para determinar el área
pues el área es justamente cuánto ocupa
este cuadrado de espacio aquí en esta
superficie de dos dimensiones que es la
pantalla o bien si estás haciendo el
problema en tu cuaderno es cuánta
superficie ocupa este cuadrado en tu
cuaderno nos interesa saber cómo esta
región pues de alguna forma medir esta
región vale y la forma en la cual se
calcula el área de un cuadrado o incluso
de un rectángulo es tomando su base y
multiplicando esa base por la altura
pero aquí como la base y la altura las
dos mil en ocho metros
8 metros entonces tendríamos que el área
de este cuadrado el área de este
cuadrado sería igual a 8 metros por 8
metros me voy a escribir por acá 8
metros s 8 que es un poco feo 8 metros
por 8 metros y esto se multiplica así 8
por 8 que era 64 y metros por metros que
da metros elevado al cuadrado o
simplemente metros cuadrados y a lo
mejor te debes estar preguntando pues de
dónde salió este este 64 por qué estamos
diciendo que el área de 64 y para eso
déjame explicarte lo haciendo este
cuadrado un poco más grande y
dividiéndolo en cuadrados más pequeños
lo voy a hacer por acá lo voy a hacer
por acá ahí tenemos ese mismo cuadrado
pero lo vamos a dividir justo justo
en cuadraditos de uno por uno más o
menos va a quedar algo así a ver si no
me quedan muy chueco bueno si quedan de
diferente tamaño no le hace simplemente
nos imaginamos que que son de uno por
uno vale entonces le voy a hacer así así
así y ahora van las líneas horizontales
más o menos a la mitad mitad
a mitad y unas mitades más vale entonces
es exactamente el mismo cuadrado pero
estoy dividiéndolo para que para que
estos ocho metros ocho metros y estos
ocho metros
ahora se separen en ocho cachitos de un
metro ahí tenemos un metro otro otro
evans cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y lo
mismo lo mismo de este lado vale si
hacemos esto entonces cada uno de estos
cuadraditos es un cuadradito de un metro
por un metro
este cuadradito es un cuadradito de un
metro por un metro y entonces cuando
decimos que el área de 64 metros
cuadrados estamos diciendo que podemos
partir este cuadrado en 64 cuadraditos
de un metro por un metro al área de uno
de estos cuadrados es a lo que le
llamamos un metro cuadrado un metro
cuadrado vale entonces estos sesenta y
cuatro salen de la observación de que
hay ocho cuadraditos de un metro por un
metro en cada renglón y tenemos ocho
renglones
las 1234 así todos los cuadraditos
serían 8 x 8 es decir 64 vale entonces
el área básicamente es esta noción de
que tanto espacio ocupa una figura
podemos pensarlo también como no sé si
esto fuera un cuarto y queremos poner
una alfombra que tanta alfombra tenemos
que poner vale bueno eso es con respecto
al área pero imagínate que te pido ahora
calcular el perímetro
el perímetro el perímetro del cuadrado
el perímetro ahora ya no tiene que ver
con cuánto espacio ocupa sino con cuánta
distancia recorremos al darle toda la
vuelta al recorrer cada uno de estos
cuatro lados vale así como teníamos la
analogía de la alfombra para el área
aquí tenemos una analogía de poner una
cerca si tenemos un terreno con esta
forma de cuadrado que tanta cerca
necesitamos para rodearlo bueno pues en
este caso tendríamos que sumar las
longitudes de los cuatro lados cada uno
es de 8 metros entonces tendría que ser
8 metros 8 metros más 8 metros más 8
metros más 8 metros
88 es 16 8 24 más 8 es 32 entonces el
perímetro sería 32 metros y observa que
aquí ya no son metros cuadrados justo
como estamos midiendo una longitud
porque es una suma de longitud es verdad
o sea podemos imaginar que estos cuatro
lados los ponemos así para formar uno
más o menos algo así como esto es una
longitud ya no tenemos metros cuadrados
sino simplemente metros vale entonces el
área el área se mide en unidades
cuadradas y el perímetro en unidades así
normales muy bien vamos a un caso un
poco más interesante que es el caso de
un rectángulo este caso lo voy a hacer
y déjame déjame borrar mi nuevo rar
porque ya no tengo espacio abajo
entonces voy a borrar y voy a hacer
ahora un rectángulo entonces imaginemos
que tenemos tenemos un rectángulo así
un poco más a la derecha un rectángulo
así y que ese rectángulo tiene de
dimensiones aquí siete centímetros y acá
cuatro centímetros
4 centímetros y que aquí te pregunto
cuál es el área y cuál es el perímetro
voy a ponerlo por acá cuál es el área
a área
voy a ponerle a un poco más bonita área
y también te pregunto cuál es el
perímetro
perímetro si quieres puedes pausar el
vídeo para intentar el problema pero ya
lo voy a explicar para encontrar el área
simplemente multiplicamos base por
altura entonces en este caso el área
sería igual a 7 centímetros 7
centímetros por 4 centímetros
vale 7 por 4 es 28 28 y centímetros por
centímetros de centímetros centímetros
cuadrados entonces simplemente volvemos
a utilizar la fórmula de base por altura
que una vez más es equivalente a empezar
a dividir este rectángulo en muchos en
muchos cuadraditos de uno por uno vale
pero no lo voy a hacer porque a lo mejor
no me queda tan bonito bueno creo que si
me va a quedar bonito más o menos algo
de este estilo más o menos algo así y
algo así vale entonces de ahí salen los
28 centímetros cuadrados y para calcular
el perímetro tenemos que sumar las
longitudes de los cuatro lados sería 7 +
siete centímetros más cuatro centímetros
más la longitud de este de arriba como
el rectángulo también es siete
centímetros más cuatro centímetros 74 es
11 718 más 4 es de 22 entonces el
perímetro sería 22 centímetros y nada
más así verdad sin cuadrados 22
centímetros muy bien ahora vamos a algo
que no sean rectángulos vamos a una
figura un poco más interesante como los
triángulos déjame empezar con los
triángulos que se parecen un poco a los
rectángulos es decir los triángulos
rectángulos imagínate que tenemos un
triángulo de esta forma de esta forma
donde este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados
algo así
y para no cambiar mucho de números vamos
a pensar que esta longitud de 7
centímetros 7 centímetros y esta
longitud de acá es 4 centímetros 4
centímetros entonces la pregunta es
cuánto sería ahora el área del área
bueno si hacemos 7 centímetros por 4
centímetros
eso sería calcular demasiada área verdad
porque eso lo que nos daría es el área
justo del rectángulo rectángulo que se
obtiene de completar por acá y por acá
por acá
entonces ahí estamos calculando
demasiado pero estamos calculando de
hecho justo el doble porque si te lo
imaginas este este triángulo de acá en
este triangulito de acá es exactamente
el mismo que este triangulito de acá
nada más que girado este lado
corresponde con este este corresponde
con este y comparten este lado de acá
entonces cuando hacemos 7 por 4 y
encontramos 28 centímetros cuadrados
estamos calculando justo el doble del
área del triángulo que nos interesaba de
esta forma para calcular el área
el área de un triángulo en el cual
sabemos que su base es be digamos y su
altura es h lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar b por h y luego dividir eso
entre 2 multiplicarlo por un medio si
hacemos el área justo de este triángulo
nos quedaría que área es igual a un
medio por 7 centímetros por 4
centímetros por cuatro centímetros esto
ya lo habíamos hecho de o 28 centímetros
eso dividido entre 2 nos dice que el
área es igual a 14
centímetros cuadrados y recuerda siempre
el área de sen unidades cuadradas muy
bien calcular el área de este triángulo
está un poco más difícil porque
tendríamos que encontrar la longitud de
este lado de este lado que es algo
difícil dejarlo marco en este lado de
acá es algo difícil porque tenemos que
utilizar algo que se llama el teorema de
pitágoras pero ahorita no nos vamos a
meter mucho con eso simplemente calcular
calcularemos el área va y resulta que
esta fórmula también funciona para otro
tipo de triángulos aunque estén un poco
suecos al que me refiero con eso déjame
hacer un triángulo verde por acá
digamos algo de este estilo algo así y
algo así o sea que este hecho de comer
aunque esté chueco me refiero a que aquí
el vértice cuando cuando lo dejamos caer
sobre este lado que hay por fuera
imagínate que es una piedrita que es un
edificio así torcido y que dejamos caer
una piedra entonces esta piedra cae
fuera del triángulo fuera del triángulo
bueno en este caso a esta altura que
recorrió la piedra es a lo que le
llamamos y pues la altura del triángulo
esta de aquí sería h y de aquí para acá
nada más
este cachito sería la base
en la base y si tenemos información de
estas dos longitudes podemos calcular el
área por ejemplo si nos dijeran que esta
base es 6
no voy a poner en color rosa que esta
base 6 y que esta altura
y esta altura es digamos 5 entonces
podemos calcular el área como sigue el
área el área es simplemente un medio
multiplicado por la base multiplicado
por la altura un medio por 6 por 5 6 por
5 es 30 y la mitad de 30 es 15 entonces
el área sería 15 15 no sé si estos son
centímetros sería 15 centímetros
cuadrados vale
muy bien y algo que me gustaría contarte
porque es muy importante es que
realmente tenemos que asegurarnos que
esta es la altura que cae la piedrita
osea que es justo la recta que va
perpendicularmente de este punto a esta
línea de acá aquí hace un ángulo del 90
por ejemplo si tuviéramos ese mismo
triángulo chueco por acá más o menos
algo así
y nos dijeran nos dijeran que esto mide
6 que esto mide 6 y que esto mide 5
estoy acá mide 5 entonces aquí no
podemos hacer nada y no podemos hacer
nada porque esto no es la altura de
hecho este de aquí sería un problema muy
difícil o sea este de acá que es difícil
difícil de hecho quizás
quizás ni siquiera está totalmente
determinada el área pero bueno lo
importante en la idea básica es que para
utilizar base por altura la altura debe
de bajar perpendicularmente hacia la
base muy bien vamos a dejarle aquí con
estas ideas de área y perímetro área es
el espacio que ocupamos en dos
dimensiones y perímetro es cuanto
recorremos para ir alrededor de la
figura nos veremos en siguientes vídeos
para seguir platicando de estas ideas